pretty crazy to think through this of
you mentioned currencies and you know
obviously we've got the situation in
Lebanon going on right now where the
protesters are seeing currency be
devalued away food prices are getting
more expensive and literally people are
just going into the street and fighting
and it's pretty straightforward if you
import half your food your currency
drops by half yeah and will it need be
taken a step further right I'm literally
going in attacking banks because the
banks won't allow the withdrawals and
they will not let them withdrawn other
currencies you have to do in Lebanese
pound and then even being smart enough
to understand like this is happening at
the central bank level and actually
going to that point maybe just talked a
little bit about on a on a global basis
as these economic situations transpire
obviously the central banks and
governments will say well we have a
couple of tools other than the strategic
moves of food production and things like
that we can manipulate interest rates we
can participate in quantitative easing
that has a lot of different effects on
economies both globally and on the
national level like how do you think
about those central bank actions kind of
overlaid on all of this I'd actually
argued that most central banks don't
have those options anymore okay most of
the world never recovered from the 2007
financial crisis the Europeans and the
Japanese for example never got their
interest rates back above zero so when
we went into this crisis there were only
a handful of countries had only had some
moderate monetary flexibility the United
States having more than everybody else
put together so I mean if in a if after
ten years of recovery you've never had
monetary recovery when you went in the
next crisis I'm sorry that's that that's
it that's the end of your currency is a
functional currency especially if it was
a hard one the demographic situation
those countries don't have consumption
the demographic situation most countries
don't have a long-range investment type
of capacity so what we've seen is the
United States was able to put out more
stimulus and everybody else put together
combined the US Federal Reserve because
it is the only hard currency that
matters was able to do more than
everybody else combined and now
countries are coming to the US Fed for
swap lines which is basically dollar
rising
mobile system and the more that happens
regardless of whether those actions are
successful or not the more the United
States has the flexibility to do
whatever it wants with monetary and
fiscal policy so that three trillion
dollars you know foreigners bought up
most of the debt most of it the Fed
didn't have to do so we still have the
option and take advantage of this later
in the year to do another couple of two
trillion dollar stimulus is over the
course of the summer in order to keep
our system moving most countries can't
even pretend to do things like that so
we haven't honestly really even started
a significant QE in this environment the
Fed has gone in and you know supported
bond markets here and there and I don't
mean to suggest that's insignificant but
it's nothing on the scale that would
need to be done in the rest of the world
and the Fed just isn't interested you
know it feels very much I think five
trillion is kind of a base number that I
see thrown around a lot and tends to
feel like there's a lot more room to go
in this world though as the US continues
to do this is this a world where the US
dollar just continues to strengthen and
we see one currency you know just fail
or be devalued materially against that
dollar remember there's only eight hard
currencies in the world right now so
this honestly in my opinion this is not
all that balled of a forecast but yeah
the US currency has nowhere to go but up
for at least a couple of decades
probably five let's go through the
contenders China wanted to open its
system up they did so about three years
ago and a trillion a half dollars of
Chinese assets fled within six months so
they slammed that shut they will never
open it again they realize that that's
never going to happen you wan will never
be a global currency and that assumes
China holds which I don't think it will
next the N the N tried to do something
that the similar to the Chinese back
from the 80s it had a similar outcome
they're not interested so they print
more currency than we do in a regular
basis despite the fact their economy is
less than one-third the size Bureau it's
not that they've mismanaged it it's just
they fail
to take advantage of what time they've
had in order to reform their system and
to prepare for what a world without
favourable demographics yes they failed
to do that so we are probably looking at
the unwinding of the year over the
course of the next few years I hope
that's not front-loaded I'm losing hope
on that when I look at European news
these days and that is the second
greatest store of value in the world and
so as that unwinds even if the deutsche
mark proves to be a rock-solid currency
everyone from the periphery is going to
be going willy nilly and most of that's
going to come to the US dollar so that's
a big surge after that's the pound
you know there's anything that everyone
in the world can agree on us that the
Brits should never be in charge of
anything ever again and the way they
handle the brexit negotiations
absolutely underline that so they're
gonna get gutted in the United States
with the trade talks and that will
probably nearly end the print presence
of the British Pound in most people's
currency baskets
they're basically folded into the NAFTA
system compared to how the rest of the
world is gonna look that's not a bad
position to be in you'll be part of the
largest market of largest investment
pool blah-blah-blah-blah but that does
mean they lose monetary autonomy after
that you're down to Canada and don't get
me wrong the Canadians run a tight ship
in terms of monetary policy but a
country of thirty five million people
cannot direct how the world is going to
work after that Chuck in Australia
Sweden Denmark New Zealand that's
everyone so you know to say that the US
dollar is just going to be the only
currency of size and that it's only
going to go up it's not a range